그리고 여기 이제 베란다 부분이네요
[음악]
저희 드디어 청담동 건물이 신주
현장이 이제 준공을 앞두고 있습니다
그 김준석 소장님이 설계하셨고 그리고
저희 bsn 건설 이제 공사한 그런
사례인데
첫 번째로 공사한 거죠 이번에 좀
준공까지 하게 돼서 되게 좀 감회가
새롭고 그 맨날 컴퓨터로 보던 그
건물이
실제로 이렇게
완성되어 있는 거 보고 되게 좀
기쁘기도 하고 설계를 지금 해주셨는데
좀 어떻게 디자인을 했는지 좀 설명해
주시면 좋을 것 같습니다
청담동 안에이면 도로변에 있는
건물이고요 주변에 좀 개발되어 있는
건물들이 있어요
외관적인 부분도 좀 다른 건물들하고
비교될 수 있으니까
차별화 될 수 있게 차별성을 좀
주려고
고려를 했고요 지역적인 특색이 있어요
청담동 자체가 많이 개방적이지 않고
좀 폐쇄적인 느낌이 있어 가지고 그런
면들을 디자인적인 측면에서 좀 반영을
했어요 그래서
도로변 쪽으로는 창들이 많이 노출되어
있지 않고 오히려 안보이는 쪽
이면도로 쪽이나 아니면 안쪽으로 창이
좀 계획이 되게끔 그런 식으로 디자인
방향을 잡고 접근을 했었습니다 그리고
경사로에 위치한 필지다 보니까
레벨을 좀 최대한 활용을 했고
디자인적인 측면에서는 이제 같은
재료의 색상을 달리함으로써 좀 매스가
분져야 돼서 좀 무거워 보이지 않지만
그래도 어느 정도 무게감이 느껴질 수
있도록 그런 방향으로 접근을 했습니다
그래서 일단 지금 저희가 있는 위치가
공부상치에 1층이에요 그래서 아무래도
경사로 있다 보니까 한계층을 이득번
건물이고 그리고 여기 앞에 보면은 그
롱브릭으로 마감해 놓은게 있어요
그래서 약간 이거랑 좀 비슷한
느낌으로 이렇게 디자인을 저희도 이제
롱부리그로 했고 건물주분이 좀 약간
모던한 느낌을 되게 좋아하셔 가지고
그거와 맞게 좀 이렇게 디자인이 된
거 같습니다 일단은 여기 이제 건물
주차장 들어가는 입구인데 여기 일단은
전 조명이 되게
마음에 들어요 뭔가 호텔에 들어온
느낌인데
지하주차장 천장 마감을 보통
노출하거나 아니면 알루미늄 스팬더라는
일반적인 많이 쓰시는데 건축주께서
조금 요청하신 사항이세요
디자인적으로도 좀 감각이 있으셔서 좀
루버 형태로 디자인을 했으면 좋겠다
말씀하셔서 제안을 드렸고 조명도 이제
루버 형태를 따른 라인 조명 형태로
같이 접목을 시켜서 좀 완성을 시켜
봤습니다 아니 이거 되게 괜찮은 거
같아요
밝은 계열로 들어가는 것보다는 어두운
계열로 도장을 하는게 전반적인
분위기를 좀 차분하게 가라앉히는데
효과적이었던 것 같습니다
그러면
본격적으로 한번 안에 들어가서 좀
보도록 하시죠 들어가기 전에 전이
부분이 제일 잘한 거 같아요 설계
중에 개인적인 생각은 지금 보시면
햇빛이 이렇게 잘 들어옵니다 여기가
지금 지하 1층이고
지하 1층 바로 진입할 수 있는
출입구가 있고
지하 2층으로 내려갈 수 있는지 직통
계단이 따로 있고요 그 상부를 오픈
시켜서 천창으로 계획을 해줬어요
그래서 말씀하신 것처럼 채광이
가능하고
지하 2층에서는 이제 계단 주변을
유리로 해서 나중에 환기도 가능하게끔
그렇게 계획이 되어 있습니다 이게
직출입할 수 있는 계단이 있으므로
인해서
출입할 수 있는 좀 좋은 환경을
만들어 주는 거 같아요
이게 사실 지하 치고
그래도 뭔가 그
뭔가 답답한 느낌은 없는 거 같아요
저
앞쪽 부분도 사실은 썬크림 공간인데
적에게는 지금 채광이 좀 그렇게 많이
가능하지는 않지만
출입문을 열어서 이제 환기할 수
있도록
여기도 이제 상부에는 1층 바닥까지
오픈이 되어 있는 상황이라서
완전히 외부에 노출되어 있지는 않지만
한 개는 충분히 가능한 그런 성큰
구조고요
그리고 화장실 구분되어 있고 아마
저기는 기계실
스프링클러치
지하 2층이 좋네요
지하층이 면적이 크죠 제일 커가지고
사실 이쪽 구간은 이제 기계식 주차
하부 공간이에요 그래서 상부가
외계 노출되어 있다 보니까는
단열재를 설치를 해서 저쪽 구간보다는
여기가 천상 높이가 좀 낮습니다 그
요거 유리로 잘한 거 같아요
답답한 느낌이 없네요
있습니다 그리고 여기 건물에 좀 특징
중에 하나가 저희가 주차를 기계식으로
좀 많이 뺐잖아요 그 얘기도 좀
해주시면 좋을 것 같아요 아무래도
건물 규모가 좀 있어요 전체 연면적이
400평 정도 되는 건물이고
지하 3층에 지상 5층짜리인데
주차대수가 7대가 필요해서
기계식 주차로 적용을 했어요 그래서
지하 3층은
기계식 주차장이 되는 거고 왜냐하면
자주식으로 주차를 하다 보니까
지하 1층 면적이 거의 다 없어지는
거예요 그래서 면접 확보를 하기
위해서 기계식 주차를 적용을 했습니다
또 지역적인 특징도 있었어요
청담동이다 보니까 대부분
직접 주차를 하시기 보다는
발렛을 많이 이용하시기 때문에 그런
부분까지 좀 고려해서
기계식 주차를 제안해 드렸습니다
지하 1층도 일단은 되게 깔끔하게 잘
돼 있어요 그래서 창도 여기 다
내가지고 개방감도 확실히 좀 있는
거고
창호로 계획을 해서 일단은 지하층
치고는 밝죠네 그쵸 아까 봤던 그
저기 기계실 있던 곳이 지금 이쪽
부분인 것 같아요
여기는 뭐 탕비실로 쓰면 될 것
같아요네 그렇게 면적이 넓지는 않은데
안쪽에 위치에 있다 보니까
단독 공간으로 사용하시면 좋을 것
같습니다
하고
여기는 지금 층고는 몇 미터 정도예요
여기 지금 구조보가 많이 좀
왜냐면 이제 우리 건물이 1조 사선
영향을 받아요 그래서 계속 이렇게
후퇴하면서
구조 기둥들이 위치가 계속 옮겨지기
때문에 하부에서 받아주는 구조보
크기들이 좀
커졌습니다 그리고 아까 지하 2층에서
보셨던 전면 쪽에 있는 선크림요
부분인데 이게 사실은 저 외부에도
노출을 할 수가 있는데
굳이 노출을 안 한게 혹시나 이제 비
오거나 하면 오수가 유입이 될까봐
바깥에도 창으로 좀
계획을 해줬고 대신에 채광하고 저쪽
옆쪽으로는 열려 있으니까
환기 가능하게끔 그런 식의
기능적으로만 활용하실 수 있게
계획을 해놨습니다
와우
5층은 친구가 좀 높아요 3.8m 아
3.8m
다른 층보다 좀 높아요
와 여기 진짜 좋다 여기 꼭대기 층은
진짜 그
ceo실로 쓰면 딱 좋을 것 같아요
전용면적이 지금 한 20평 정도
그리고 여기 이제 베란다 부분이네요
이쪽 방향이 북측 방향이라서 지금
아래층에서부터 계속해서 호텔을 해서
올라오는 형태로
구성이 됐고요 사실이 위에 있는 이런
가벽 같은 것들을
디자인적인 요소로서
아무래도 건물이 조금 이렇게
균형이 맞아 보이고 엣지가 있어
보인다고 해야 되고 이게 없으면 그냥
딱 이렇게 돼 있어 가지고 계속
이렇게 꺾이는 형태로만 보여주니까 아
여기 너무 좋은데요 5층
실제로 보면 6층이잖아요 그죠
6층 높이죠
6층 높이 그리고
화장실
아니 이거 이거 무조건 달아야 돼
이거
완전 저는 개인적으로 강추하는 거울
중에 하나입니다 이게 약간 조명이
여성분들이 되게 좋아요
깔끔해가지고 여기서 이제 사진 많이
찍거든요 그리고 여기 화장실에는 지금
큐비클을 별도로 설치를 했어요 사실
이런 1인 화장실에서는 설치를 안
하기도 하는데 대변교하고 소변기하고
좀 불리하시기를 원하셔서
여자 화장실에는 사실 이제 소변기가
필요 없으니까
청소용 싱크를 설치를 해놨는데 이거는
사실 선택하실 사항이신 것 같아요
그래서 보통은 그냥
꼭대기에 있는 면적은 그렇게 크지
않아서 그냥 하나만 만들어 놓는
경우가 많은데 근데 두 개를 해가지고
잘 뺀 거 같아 전증 다 남녀로
분류해서
분리가 되게 중요하거든요
화장실에 따라서
여성 직원이 채용이 되냐 안 되냐
이것도 사실 결정되기도 하거든요 되게
중요한 요소입니다
네 여기는 이제 4층이고 여기도 이제
발코니가 이렇게 설치가 되어 있습니다
여기는 몇 평 정도 되죠 여기가
전용면적 27평 27평
위로 올라갈수록 면적이 점점
줄어들고요 아까
5층이 좀 친구가 높아서 그런지
여기도
낮은 층고는 아니에요 지금 3.3m
여기는 좀 여기
베란다 부분이 좀 더 넓은 거 같아요
아래층 바닥면적이 더 커서 그만큼
호체되는 부분이 많아져서
베란다 면적이 좀 더 넓게 확보가
되어 있어요 여기는 좀 느낌이 좀
다른 거 같아요 아까 위에랑
베란다하고는 확실히 느낌도 다르고
활용도도 다르실 거예요
여기는 그 일조권 사선을 좀 안 받는
곳이에요 그래서 이제 딱 그 면적이
제일 크게 잘 나와 있는데
전용면적으로 한 42평 정도 아 전용
40에
그래서 딱 그 사무실 공간으로 쓰기
딱 좋은 거 같아요 면적 자체가
그래도 다른 층에 비해서 좀 넓어서
한층을
활용하시기에는 가장 좋을 것 같아요
다른 층하고 이제 다른게
외부
베란다가 없고
창이 지금
다른 층들은 바닥까지 내려오는
긴장들이었는데 여기는 이제 하버에
이제 턱이 있는 그런 창으로 계획을
한게 아무래도 사무실 용도로
적합할 수 있겠다 싶어서 책상을 놨을
때 이미지를 고려해서 또 창으로
있습니다 그리고 다른 건물들은
3층까지 이제 사상 제한 안 받고
최대 면접을 확보할 수 있는데 우리는
아무래도 경사지형이어서 가중평균도
적용하다 보니까 2층까지만 이제 넓은
면적으로 확보가 가능했고 3층부터
이제 사상자를 받아서 후퇴가 시작됐죠
그리고 1층에 왔는데 1층에 일단
바로 들어올 수 있게 이렇게 계단이
있네요 아까 지하 1층으로도 바로
진입할 수 있도록 출입구가 있고요 또
1층으로도 바로 직접 출입할 수 있는
출입구가 있고 사실이 건물에 메
1층에 있습니다
타일 이거 잘 고른 거 같아요 그래서
각 계단실로 통하는 출입문들이 다
방화 성능을 갖고 있는 방화문으로
시공이 돼야 돼요 그래서 저희도
이렇게 방화문으로 시공을 했지만
매립형
타입으로 해서
평소에는 열려 있고 비상시에만 닫히는
구조로
문이 설치가 됐습니다 저는 제일 눈에
띄는게 여기
테라스 공간입니다
아니 이게
지하 주차장 상부예요 지금 그래서
경사지형이다 보니까이 부분을 이제
1층에서 테라스로 활용을 할 수 있게
된 거죠
그러니까 지금 엄청 넓습니다
축구해도 되게
그래서 여기 좀 꾸며 가지고
쓰면 너무 좋을 것 같아요 그래서
사실이 공간을 테라스로 활용을 하다
보니까
지상에 노출되어 있는 빈 공간이
없어요 그래서
지하하고 지상에 대한 실외기를 일부
이제 테라스에 배치를 할 수밖에
없었고 나머지는
절반을 이제 옥상으로 설치를 했고요
법정 조경 설치해야 되는 대상이기
때문에 또 조경 공간도 일부는
테라스에 나머지는 이제 건물 후면에
처치를 했습니다 그리고 여기가 바로
이제 옆 건물 하고 경계선인데 여기가
지금 현재
옆 건물이 철거해 놓은 상태라
위험해서 난간 높이는 조금 더 높게
시공을 해놨어요 저쪽 구간은 그리고
아까 지하 2층에서 보셨던 상부 천창
구간이고 사실 저 유리를 강화유리로
해서
난간에 설치하지 않을 수도 있는데요
그래도 또 혹시 모르잖아요
[음악]
이렇게 이제 보는 길목마다
블라드 등이랑 해서
야외 조명을 또 설치를 할 거예요
야간에도 또 더 이쁘게 활용하실 수
있도록 여기서 진짜 직원들이랑
바베큐라든지 뭐 해서
쓰기에 진짜 너무 좋은 것만
대게 모던하고
깔끔하고이
땅에서 쓸 수 있는 그런 포인트들을
되게 잘 살렸던 거 같고 그리고 이제
천창이라든지 이렇게 그 내가
천창이라든지 아니면 이제 여기 베란다
부분 그 부분을 또 되게 잘 살린
부분이 좋고
무엇보다 저는 여기 1층 여기 테라스
공간이
회사 운영하는 입장에서는 너무 좋은
나중에
직원들이랑 쓰기에 너무 좋은 공간
같습니다 그래서 오늘 영상 여기까지
하고요
다음 시간에 또 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다